big news from the u.s supreme court
liberal justice stephen breyer is
apparently being shown the door earlier
today well he didn't make the
announcement someone else leaked his
retirement plan then a short time later
the white house proudly confirmed joe
biden's strategy to fill breyer's spot
now biden said he will make his pick
based purely purely on race and gender
and promised only an african-american
woman will be selected jonathan turley a
democrat questions the constitutionality
of this criteria he wrote this precisely
what the supreme court already declared
to be unconstitutional
discrimination we'll have more of his
article coming up and we'll break
biden's potentially break it all down
his unlawful potential unconstitutional
strategy but first another
groundbreaking morning at the white
house get this joe biden actually had a
public event that did not involve ice
cream unfortunately for joe
didn't go particularly well take a look
uh i'm always talking about corvettes i
don't make ford or anybody else upset
but uh
i might point out you're uh
when i went to dearborn driving that
uh you know uh was up there i don't know
man
it uh
i think the press thought i was crazy i
enjoyed it so much going up and
uh your new ev factory and
and that that hummer
i don't know man i don't know last week
biden said he had no idea why americans
doubt his mental fitness he believes his
first year in office was a tremendous
success and that he has exceeded all
expectations the american people they
strongly disagree look at this new
monmouth poll
that has biden's approval at another
all-time low in their case 39 percent
the same polls showing republicans up by
eight points on the generic ballot
remember last year they were down nine
and today one former clinton adviser
told america's newsroom that he has
rarely ever seen poll numbers this bad
take a look
the president has the double-barreled
problem
of people are upset that the that the
virus is continuing but i think even
more importantly now that inflation has
has raged and therefore so few people
think the economy is going in the right
direction as you know when things are
going badly the ins get voted out uh and
and that can be a very powerful force
here and i i rarely have seen numbers
this bad uh in recent times
and mark penn is a well-respected
pollster will the biden administration
ever recover now forget his cognitive
struggles for just a second analysts now
predict that the price of oil could now
soon surge to a hundred and fifty
dollars a barrel that's a hundred
percent increase make no mistake joe
biden is green new socialist bosses in
the democratic party the cult of climate
change they want this to happen it's all
part of the plan they want oil and gas
to be expensive and limited obama even
once himself admitted he wanted gas
prices to go up but just not just not
this quickly
now americans will suffer inflation will
soar but according to them it will all
be worth it as america's fundamentally
transformed into a greener and
progressive society hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else